so you know in the 90s you know before
many of you were born I suspect um
Martin and I started a company to do
electronic books and this was when that
was really hard and and there's Martin
holding up a rocket ebook which was a
you know minor success it ended up
getting sold to Jem Star TV Guide and
right away you should ask questions if
you're a book company and a and TV Guide
buys you you got to kind of wonder about
your future however in 2000 the future
was quite uncertain it was a very good
acquisition everybody was fine so we
wondered what to do next and we did
think about perhaps not doing anything
next but that didn't seem right and the
reason why and I think many of you know
this I hope that's why you're here is
that because there are really things
worth changing there are things worth
the sort of hard work that it takes to
change and to create something new so we
wanted to find a problem that we cared
about
then we cared about all kinds of things
and there are so many problems and
there's Leslie Zeiss right there polar
bear which is related we care about so
many things but the one that we picked
in 2003 was oil now we picked books
before now frankly it was a personal
peeve was in the 90s we were both
traveling a lot for various reasons and
we read a lot we had all these books and
it was just a pain to carry them I know
it sounds crazy but at the time books
were these physical things and you
couldn't just read them on a screen
screens didn't the screens were not good
enough that technology did not exist yet
that allowed a readable surface in a
small form-factor so we picked oil this
time after a bunch of iterations of what
to do next and oil is really a problem
and I hope that most of you are kind of
aware of this but clearly it is one of
the key contributors to global warming
you know we generate Giga tons of co2 we
release Giga tons of co2 from from the
ancient past into our current future
there's also this issue of of peak oil
which was very hot in 2003 but it people
misunderstood it it's really peak oil at
a given price you know at $500 a bear
we can you know get oil until we don't
have any planet left but at $20 a barrel
that oil is all gone so it has an
economic impact as well obviously
economics itself are impacted by our
incredible consumption of oil it sends
an enormous amount of wealth to other
parts of the world and that is not
necessarily in our best interest and
then finally that creates the politics
that we see now and I don't think
anybody you know although technically
you know if you talk to the you know
people in Washington they say that but
there's nothing involving oil with
politics that there's no connection
between what's going on the middle east
and our dependence on oil I think most
people would disagree with that the
interesting thing from an entrepreneurs
perspective is that there are all these
problems at once created by oil and that
means that there's lots of people
interested in solving them all at once
interested in a solution for oil so you
have to look to see where you use oil
and this is the case of anything you're
trying to replace where where you use it
and in this case it's really
transportation notice that you know
essentially electric power generation at
least in the United States is
essentially zero that's almost entirely
in Hawaii there's a funny reason for
that that's its own sort of mini lecture
and then within within transportation
it's largely or cars which is you know
if you're going to do something it's
going to be a car so we didn't know
anything about cars what we did know was
that electric motors and electric
systems were incredibly efficient and
and that is something that we studied
very deeply we worked at the well two
wheel energy efficiency of all of the
possible fuels and at that time in 2003
there was a lot of interest in hydrogen
fuel cells it sort of comes in you know
there's a there's an adage in the car
industry that hydrogen fuel cells is the
future of mobility and always will be
and and I think that that's it's true
because the energy equation is terrible
is just terrible it's incredibly
inefficient it makes gasoline look
tremendously efficient at providing
transportation so we looked at all in
electric cars and there's a whole
lecture that I have just on that topic
electric cars were the were the most
efficient way using by almost any
resource that you could imagine
electric cars were the most efficient
way of moving around so we were pretty
sure that electric cars that was what
we're gonna do but how do you make a car
how do you understand that industry
because these industries are very big
and you have to do a lot of research so
we asked everybody we subscribe to all
the industry rags we got you know met
everybody that we could and across out
here is a little bit hard you know the
most of it is centered in Detroit
but still we managed to talk to a lot of
people and we discovered a lot about the
car industry you know it starts 100
years ago it's really really big it's
incredibly efficient at manufacturing
the car industry is unbelievably
efficient at manufacturing almost
exactly what it was manufacturing last
year the colors might change the body
shape might change but in general they
don't change much else and you can see
that in DW you know they had these
diesel things and then when it became
problematic they simply cheated on the
test because actually changing that kind
of change is really hard for the car
industry they're very slow to change
precisely because they're so big and so
efficient there isn't a lot of room to
maneuver in that world which is great if
you're an entrepreneur so we also
started setting the customer and this is
really important because I believe that
anything that's going to to help with
climate change ultimately you have to
provide for the customer so the customer
is really important in this and cars are
especially that way because they're
they're expensive and people but
everyone buys one so you got to please
the customer and there's lots of lots of
options to choose from customer surveys
I don't believe in generally if you ask
people you know there's a there's a old
saying that you know if you wouldn't if
Henry Ford asked did a customer survey
about cars everyone would say the car
thing not so sure what I really want is
a horse that doesn't eat so much and and
that is it's difficult for customer to
envision the reality that isn't there
yet like this woman is clearly thrilled
at her purchase of a giant mushroom
thing and if you had done a customer
survey that said do you envision
yourself buying giant mushroom things
you know nobody's going to say yes and
she was thrilled thrilled by this very
difficult to know what the customer is
gonna do you have to kind of guess and
then this is you know incredibly
overused world word as disruption I
don't mean it in the sort of well I
guess maybe a little bit in the modern
context but what happens especially in
these big industries remember they're
really slow to change so as they're slow
to change things change underneath them
manufacturing changes and they don't
really notice and I'm sure that 20 years
ago or 30 years ago they looked at
electric cars and said the act you know
it doesn't work you know the batteries
are never going to be good enough we
don't need to fund another research
study into that so as technology changes
they don't tend to notice that right
away and they're very very large so they
you know it's kind of the the inertia or
the momentum that they have is huge
so that is again very good for
entrepreneurs whether you're dealing
with the oil industry or car industry or
your power company they're not really
set up for things changing underneath
them the assumptions changing so with
books it was easy because the internet
was changing everything you know
software was going everywhere and the
internet and you know was happening and
you could distribute digital content and
the publishers were completely freaked
because Napster had existed and wiped
out the music industry so they were they
knew that they were change was coming
and they didn't want change but they
didn't know what to do about it
and you know we had a solution for them
which worked out great in the car
industry we tried to ask ourselves did
any think it was anything changing there
so technology we knew was changing
batteries were getting better we knew
that from the consumer electronics world
every year the batteries got cheaper and
better
we went from mic heads to nickel metal
hydrides to lithium ion and then within
each one of those the chemistry's every
year cranked better and better and
better and cheaper cheaper cheaper like
a really slow Moore's Law so that
changes the underlying assumptions of a
lot of things you know do electric cars
make sense well they didn't you know in
1990 you know five but they sort of did
by 2003 and their trajectory is good you
want to get into something when it's
hard because when it's really obvious
and easy everyone else is there already
so it was clear that the batteries were
gonna by the time we even got into
manufacturing the batteries are going to
better and cheaper which was exactly
true so that was clear but no one was
buying electric cars in 2003 the
industry that as a market if you will
was really not going well and this was
what was on sale in 2003 these were the
cars that you could buy as a you know
car consumer if you wanted to go
electric if you really wanted to
decarbonize and go electric now these
were not selling at all in fact almost
all of those only they ever made a few
of them and nobody could understand why
and the the sort of Industry answer was
because nobody wants electric cars
nobody thought well maybe nobody wants
incredibly lame electric cars because
are in Martin you know coined this term
he said you know these are punishment
cars these are these are written or
created by people who hate the idea that
you might be not riding your bike or
taking public transit and therefore if
you are just insist on having an elect a
car you have to be punished for it and
it has to be one of those things now
there were other cars that existed
before 2003 and this is the the best of
them the 81 and it was actually a fairly
decent electric car it was the only
electric car made by sort of a real car
company if you will purpose-built to be
an electric car we have had in the late
2009 days a thing called in California
called a zero emissions mandate we've
said that if you go to sell cars in
California you got to also sell some
zero emission cars you got to have these
zero emission credits and all the car
companies applied vast amounts of money
to Sacramento to fix that and they spent
a little bit of money on electric cars
and eventually the money flowing into
Sacramento fixed it for them and in 2002
they got it rewritten and all of these
cars were pulled back and crushed but as
a case study of why we thought electric
cars might work it was really
instructive because there were people
who really loved these cars in fact many
of them became our initial customers and
this was by far the best of those cars
although the Eva the rav4 had quite a
following as well now the thing that was
interesting from
GM is that he didn't want to sell you
the car they would only lease you the
car that way when the lobbying was
successful in Sacramento they could pull
back the leases and have them crushed
and in fact they were so adamant of
making sure that there were no eveyone's
around that there were two outside of
their hand outside of the leasing
arrangement one was held by the
Smithsonian and I don't think it was
necessarily a coincidence that they paid
a great deal of money to have the new
beautiful car museum done at the new
location for the Smithsonian and one of
the requirements for their you know
largesse to the Smithsonian was that the
ev1 not be displayed because and the
quote is great I wish I had it here
because it's really about the past and
we shouldn't be looking back into the
past now it is a car museum one would
think that would be an OK thing to have
but GM really really didn't want it and
there's one in university hands and they
couldn't buy it back from the University
so he wanted them all crushed for
whatever weird internal reason for GM
the thing that we learned about it
though is they said you know the reason
why we had them crush is they just
wasn't enough interest in them basically
only tree huggers and geeks like these
cars now they were only available in
California because their emissions
mandate but you know and we thought well
maybe in California especially I mean
we're kind of tree huggers and geeks
maybe there's enough of us that would do
that but maybe we could make something
that's even more more appealing so who
were these people that were buying this
car are releasing this car and this is a
big revelation that we had was like this
punishment cars there was this belief
that electric cars were about saving
money and we went to raise money
many times the VCS would say well when
will your car pay for itself and you
know we ended up making a sports car as
many of you know and in general sports
cars do not pay for themselves and the
VCS all have sports cars so you can
always say hey well what what kind of
sports car do you have and they saw I've
got a Porsche Turbo whatever and then
you ask well when will that pay for
itself and they say oh no no it's
different it's gasoline it doesn't you
know it
electric cars have to pay for themselves
well we didn't believe that and the
reason why we
because the ev1 the people who lease
that car were rich
this is in you know the late late 90s
early 2000s and it was the highest
income demographic in California that's
tracked this is huge the only time that
GM has ever sold to that demographic
because when you when you it you know if
you if you are suddenly rich you don't
go buy out the latest oldsmobile or
whatever I mean you know you buy the
Mercedes or the BMW you don't go to GM
so the only time that they actually
really hit that demographic they then
pulled back all of the cars from those
customers and crushed them in front of
their lawyers eyes which there's the
stories that these customers who later
became Tesla customers tell us it is
hard to imagine as a company that you
could treat your most passionate and
well-connected and wealthy at high
demographic customers like that you you
you almost it is beyond any management
book that you can imagine anyway the
other thing that happened was the Prius
came out and the priest came out in
California for a variety of really
interesting reasons in Japan some weird
reasons in in in Washington DC years
before in California and it immediately
ate into Lexus sales and that was not in
the roadmap for Toyota Toyota had put it
on their cheapest possible platform they
did not expect it to appeal to wealthy
people because wealthy people had money
they didn't need to worry about paying
for gas and instead they were trading in
their Alexis's to get Priuses which were
at that time there was a like an $8,000
premium because they were in such short
supply this was a real problem for
Toyota because that premium is not it
doesn't accrue to Toyota that gets you
know kept by the dealer and they were
losing money on every Prius but they of
course you know the Lexus is our highest
margin cars so the idea that you go into
their most successful California market
in the u.s. you released this sort of
low end car and it consumes the high-end
was not entire display at all but it
again said that it wasn't about saving
money and then of course this was gas
was a dollar fifty a gallon at this
it it was some of the cheapest gas we
had ever had during this period it
adjusted for for inflation so it was
clear to us that this whole idea of
trying to save money on cars was a
mistake and that the actual people who
might be interested we're people who
could afford to to do the right thing
for whatever reason because it turns out
that cars are a little different than
most products well maybe they're the
same as all products but they're very
expensive so they seem different people
buy cars really to project their values
if you think about it all the cars in
California especially all go exactly the
same speed I mean you're not going 200
miles an hour in that Lamborghini you
are hoping to get to 65 on 280 and
probably not going that fast
not even getting to 65 and you're going
right there with that little Ford Fiesta
is right next to you so if you were just
doing it to save money or do the most
economical thing everyone would buy a
very very very cheap car and yet the
moment that people have some excess
disposable income they tend to buy a new
car and they they spend more money on
the car they don't just replace it with
the cheapest possible thing they buy a
car maybe it's a big SUV to go to the
mall or whether it's a you know a sports
car to project whatever image that is
but they do it to project their values
and to tell people and to show people
their image and for electric cars and
for the Priuses I mean Paulo else it was
filled with Priuses importance Prius is
important every Drive a Prius an
abortion because they wanted to let
everybody know how sort of morally
superior they were because they had the
Porsche to but you know they had they
had that that Prius that they drove even
though they were spending you know far
more at Starbucks or whatever than they
were at the gas station so this is
really important to us because we could
not make a car remember I said that the
car industry was super super efficient
there is no way we could make a car at
any price point anywhere close to what
the car industry that makes millions of
cars a year any company we just would if
we if we had to compete on price it's
not a competition
so it had to be something else had to be
something that that we're offering the
customer that they
want that the regular car industry had
forgotten about or didn't realize so our
target customers were the people that
were buying Priuses but really could
afford a Porsche or anything else that
they wanted and it turns out that
there's a lot of those one of the great
things about the car industry from a
marketing perspective is that all of the
data is public because cars get
registered when you buy a car you
register it to drive it you get a
license plate and that data is public so
you can go and see exactly what cars got
sold where and you know who's driving
what it's great so you know that well
for sports cars there's only a handful
of markets which was great if you're
introducing a new product you only need
to introduce it in a few markets it's
you know LA and San Francisco and Miami
and New York and I think oh and settle
in Houston I think - and that's sort of
like all the sports cars in the country
get sold basically in those markets and
there's also happened to be many of
those places
our people were people that were also
very concerned about global warming or
about the politics so many of our
initial customers really didn't care
much about global warming or didn't
believe in it but they really cared
about sending their money to the Middle
East so that was and you know as
somebody selling these cars and wanting
to decarbonize the transportation sector
I don't really care why people want to
decarbonize you know it's if they want
to save trees or ice you know that's one
thing if they want to simply you know
try to keep the money at home for
economic reasons that's great if they're
worried about national security
that's great - I don't care so we
believed all the places where everything
was was ready for disruption in the car
industry and we had to figure what kind
of card to build so we knew that the
demographic could afford a sports car
there was reasons why we chose a sports
car we did a lot of modeling and we did
not use supercomputers we actually used
high school math and spreadsheets and we
modelled it almost exactly correctly we
were only off by a few percent because
it turns out math is unbelievably
predictive you know and and this is not
deep physics this is you know this is
sort of Newtonian physics and an energy
it's it's
great and it's something that any high
school student can do if you're if
you're patient and and good with Excel
and along the way we're trying to figure
out what we could build this is the
image that really stuck with me
Martin dug this up somewhere and I when
I saw it I it really resonated because
if you look at the average driving in
California and the average sunshine in
California that's what it takes that
that's that person you know with a with
a Tesla or you know any kind of actually
you know electric car that's all the
amount of solar panels you need to drive
about fourteen thousand miles in
California you know different parts of
the country is a little different but
that looked doable to me that was not
some crazy infrastructure change that
was not a trillion dollars of new
hydrogen super highways it was that this
little tiny you know set of solar panels
it's not even very big and a car and
then you're completely decoupled from
from a you know hydrocarbon future and
that I just think is so powerful because
it looks very doable so the computer
model showed us we could make a sports
car there's another thing that's
important about marketing your new
solution is that I believe it has to be
better than the alternative
it can't be a punishment car we know
that those didn't sell and one of the
things that electric can do really
really well it has some shortcomings but
the thing it can really do is accelerate
like crazy and it turns out that people
pay for that all the sports cars are
priced according to the 0-60 time the
faster the quicker you get to zero to 60
the more expensive the sports car and
there are people who are willing to pay
fifty thousand dollars more to get half
a second off it's great you know in it
but I I don't totally get a B it's fun
it's really fun but I guess that's
enough so and that for second 0-60 was
right about where the supercars were at
that time
now they're about 2.5 seconds which is
incredibly the latest Model S can do it
I think in 2.8 seconds so it's giant
you know five-passenger sedan and it's
faster than you know the supercars were
only you know ten years ago or five even
five years ago sports car you know
Subaru sports guys so this is what you
know we we came up with with something
that would be compelling and
I also you know teach a lot about you
know how to start a company in
entrepreneurship
this is really important you know has to
be better solution has to be better it's
going to be really quick it's going to
be environmentally friendly it's going
to be super fun to drive and with the
ebooks you know there's lots of
advantages I mean now that it looks very
quaint and you know bizarre Stone Age
like but we had lots of very committed
customers who would write they organized
their own conference around electronic
books because they were so enamored with
this experience and when we went to two
cars I mean it was the same thing like
we had this really hot sports car we
wanted it to be beautiful electric cars
do not have to look goofy there's no
reason there's no physics doesn't say oh
if it's electric it's got to look like a
golf cart or it's got a it has to look
like a clown car it can be any shape you
want that turns out to just be sort of
sheet metal or carbon fibre or whatever
and it's not gonna have any tailpipe
emissions it's going to have you know
great energy efficiency and it's gonna
be super fast and it's really a better
driving experience and the the sports
car had some of limitations because of
our design cycle and how we had to get
into the market but the Model S was
really what we wanted in a sense of a
custom-built electric car something that
all of our learning and and not having
to be based a little bit on an old
internal combustion engine platform so
the Model S is a great car it's super
quick in fact as I haven't updated the
slides since the the D came out
incredibly efficient and everyone says
it's you know the magazine's say you
know Car of the Year whatever the only
time all the judges said it was the best
car they've ever driven
Consumer Reports said you know they've
never had reviewed a car that was as
good and they gave it the highest rating
that ever given and then this year they
gave it a higher rating than their
rating system it was 102 points out of
100 and so they have to quite figure out
what they're gonna do about that yet so
it really is it delights the customer
and that you know asking people to
change behavior to save the world is
very hard because people might do it for
a little while but in the end they
kind of like the way that it was because
it's been really convenient the way our
world is structured it has to be better
so these big projects require lots of
people so if you guys are out starting
something and you've spent a couple of
years and you've been unable to convince
anybody to help you or anybody to join
you there may be a reason for that just
just saying visions especially around
the environment and climate change and
sustainability should be really
compelling people should get it and if
your vision isn't right for some reason
and you can't attract anyone to help you
you know maybe it's not one of those
things you may want to change that
vision a little bit I see there are lots
of startup plans and some of them are
really a hard sell you know they can't
convince anybody and there's a reason
for it so what's next and this as this
course teaches you know there's lots and
lots of things going on that we need to
fix and it's not that these are nice
things to fix we really have to do it
because the way we're currently doing it
you know isn't gonna last and we say oh
it isn't sustainable well there's a
great quote by an economist and it says
you know if something cannot go on
forever it will stop and it doesn't feel
like it though it feels like interest
rates will always be zero it feels like
we're always going to be able to to go
to a gas station and just get more you
know gas it feels like there will always
be ice in the Arctic because our as
humans we're not evolved to deal with
these super long range problems and the
way the market systems work is they tend
to not price in the resource depletion
so you know there are minerals there are
rare earth minerals that we use you know
that are in here that we're kind of
running out of we don't know a lot of
other sources for them and we have you
know 20 30 years worth maybe but then
there won't be anymore because their
elements you know they're made inside of
supernovas it's hard for us to make
elements it would be better for us not
to use the
recklessly and throw them into the
garbage when they're done but recycle
them for example so it really will
change everything because a lot of the
things we do are not sustainable and it
really little mean if it's not
sustainable it will stop different
things stop at different times but
everything that isn't sustainable
by definition stops so it's gonna be a
big change and for whatever reason I
have occasionally attracted people who
really want to go back to the earth well
you know kind of on the earth you know I
come into that but and you know they
want to live and raise goats and live in
yurts and stuff and that is really great
and I've had this discussion on numerous
times but that isn't necessarily the
lifestyle that I want I have nothing
against goats but I don't really want to
interact with them on a daily basis and
I like living in a world that has lots
of really cool things and neat stuff and
things we can go do so my belief is that
that is really where we should focus we
should try to make these things a future
in which our technology is helping us
and the way that we we survive I think
is by applying science and technology
just insanely because we've done it
enough to really mess us up we've gotten
you know giant populations and stuff and
we'd better fix it but the thing is
there's nothing the physics lets us fix
it it's just an engineering problem hard
one but so I always leave with you know
what will you change and I have some
baby picture slides of Tesla which I
could go through if you guys want but or
I can answer questions so anyway that's
that's sort of my my takeaway or might
why that's my presentation to try to get
people to fix things because all these
things stop now I want to make one more
point is that because almost no systems
currently are sustainable as an
entrepreneur this is a great thing
because it means that almost anything
that you want to pick if you're really
into making you know glasses you can
probably find things that are not
sustainable in glass making or you know
eyeglasses and disrupt that market
because those assumptions have changed
and you should be able to go in and
those things the whole economy is going
to be rebuilt in the next 3040 years and
if that isn't the biggest possible
opportunity to rebuild the largest
economy the world has ever known and the
most materially rich society we've ever
had I mean what more do you want is an
entrepreneur I mean I just don't know so
I really think that that what you change
is going to be huge because everything
is going to change you will still have
iPhones but they're not going to be made
the same way I can guarantee it yes well
so part of it is the entrepreneurial
enthusiasm and naivety now you would say
but also most problems so electric cars
were you know I'm a software guy
Martin's an electrical engineer you know
I knew from the software perspective and
electrical engineering perspective we
could make electric cars they've been
around for a hundred years
so the technology itself of the
drivetrain was not a big problem I mean
there was lots of issues but they were
engineering problems and they were
engineering problems that Silicon Valley
knows how to solve its power electronics
it's software it's you know advanced
manufacturing techniques its efficiency
we do that that's what Silicon Valley is
all about making the car was what scared
me and that's how he partnered with
Lotus to make this screw together the
actual car for the first one because we
didn't know how and we knew we couldn't
add any value to that particular piece
of the equation yet I was actually not
the excisions Exige didn't exist
it was the lease oh yeah so the reason
why we picked Lotus as opposed to any of
the other car companies on the planets
partner worth is that they had
experience making cars for other people
so they had made the opel speedster for
GM they had made some other car for some
other european company they also had an
impedance match if you try imagine you
in the
- guys we try to go to you know forward
and say we want you to build cars under
our name I mean they're never ever in a
million years gonna do that Lotus is
used to making small numbers of cars
they only make you know five thousand
cars a year anyway so and to keep their
factory busy they do work for other
people so they were a perfect fit we had
several other possible fits there's a
company in South Africa that is a very
similar thing but Lotus lotus was a good
fit size-wise and they had all of the
they had cars that were already
federally approved here so they had
experience with that and then the final
thing is that because England is filled
with little tiny car companies that most
of which I've never heard of unless
you're a real enthusiast they have an
entrepreneurial system they're around
cars which we don't have it all we have
like the big three and that's it they
have an entire ecosystem that deals with
little car companies which is great it's
a little bit it's a little bit like a
very small version of Silicon Valley
around certain technologies yeah and
Chris and sort of a new revolution
greenforest imagine people not realize
that big cars which I'm going to pull
bought as an image name like designer
quotes or was it that the the value of a
green image was sort of undervalued well
that's a really good question the car
industry obviously knows that I mean
they wouldn't make all these different
flavors of cars and market it so
carefully to people they clearly know
that people buy cars for their image for
their personal you know projection why
they thought that no one would want to
project that for an electric car is
beyond me and especially when they had
data that said it was not the I mean
Prius sales and and there because a
Prius is a fine car but it's you know
it's not as nice as that Porsche the
people are that Lexus people were
trading in was a misstep because things
had changed I suspect that 20 years
before nobody cared nobody realized the
damage that we were doing with
hydrocarbons I think
don't yes first okay sorry so BTW mine
battery's still yes it's what is like
their big disadvantage or challenges
that yours are expensive yeah
lithium-ion batteries so letting my
batteries have challenges they they can
catch fire now I want you to realize
that what we're competing against is
gasoline and it turns out gasoline is
also quite flammable and and if you
listen to you know the traffic reports
almost every day you know there's some
car fire someplace right nobody thinks
anything that was gas and of course it
all catches fire and burns but a battery
oh my gosh you know if that were to
catch fire who knows what would happen
it turns out that you know anytime we
have that much sort of energy and
chemical energy you can have things can
go awry but just like we've got an
incredibly good at dealing with gasoline
we got you know we spent a lot of time
getting good with lithium-ion batteries
that you know you can if you handle them
correctly they're way safer than
gasoline because you know it doesn't
just a spark doesn't set it off you mean
you got a really work at it and then you
got to work at it to propagate it so as
long as you're careful about that
they're easier to deal with the thing
that's interesting about batteries or
the thing that has an added safety
concern is that they have lethal
voltages and that's the case with all
Priuses and all hybrids and stuff
because you have to have the voltage up
otherwise the cables get huge and and
there you just have to be careful but
you know we use lots of things that are
dangerous and we're good at that
I mean gasoline is super dangerous I
mean those tankers yeah oh my gosh if
you were just imagine coming into the
market and say hey I've got this great
idea we're gonna you know dry these
giant tankers filled with explosives
around we're gonna you know have
everyone just fill the car I mean know
if people would never there we go that's
if you tried to sell that now but we're
good at it so it doesn't seem like it's
a problem yes
I was simply going to suggest that when
the questions slow down do I have all
this change the world as the future
economy is going to change because most
of the thing that we are using today our
mind right so so till when you know we
can say that actually leveraging storage
in electrochemical methodology that
would be it's a very good question so
you know is lithium-ion batteries are
they sustainable so one thing is that
they're incredibly recyclable so a
little bit like you know lead acid
batteries like you have in your car let
is super toxic it's a heavy metal like
the heaviest metal that isn't
radioactive lithium is a light metal the
lightest metal in fact that is metal and
in room temperature so many of the
toxicity issues don't exist with
lithium-ion batteries in fact they're
the only battery that you can legally
throw into a landfill alkaline batteries
and all those primary cells there all
kinds of toxic stuff going on and of
course Alette is super bad but
lithium-ion batteries there's no they're
almost completely non-toxic so the thing
is you would never throw them into a
landfill because they actually have
recycle value especially some of the
other additives you put in like cobalt
is very valuable so you can you know let
acid batteries for car batteries 99% are
recycled even the ones stolen are
recycled because that's how you monetize
stealing them is you steal them and you
take them to the recycling plant that's
how you get it get the money
so lithium-ion batteries are the same
way so in a in a world which uses a lot
of lithium-ion batteries at the moment
most of them are in laptops and
cellphones and they don't get recycled
very efficiently cars use a lot of cells
you know thousand times more cells than
in a laptop so it's actually much easier
to recycle them because they come in
like one unit
and so there's a lot more value there so
I think that that is sustainable that
way the other thing is we happen to have
lots of sources of lithium so we if it
eventually becomes a problem because we
didn't recycle correctly or whatever
we'll have to deal with that but that'll
buy us another 100 or 200 years or
something yeah so that that's not so bad
okay so how did we get the VCS to agree
this is before the word clean tech
existed and then had a bad rap
afterwards but so we sort of knew we had
raised money before and we knew a lot of
VCS and we also knew that none of them
were going to invest in a car company
they it's just not gonna happen
at least that's what we figured so we
did shake the money trees that way but
we targeted specific VC's funds that
were quite small tend to only have one
or two partners large funds have lots
and lots of partners and generally you
need unanimous consent to make an
investment in most firms so if you have
to convince eight people that investing
in a car company is a great idea that's
unlikely but if you go after small funds
that may only have one partner or two
partners you only got to convince one or
two people so we had gone and convinced
some friends and family of course and
then we also had convinced a couple of
the smaller firms to invest in our first
round and then in this was in so we
started in 2003 in July and we started
looking for money in 2004 and we ran we
were also approaching large angels and
that's how we found Elan so Elan you
know it was interested in decarbonizing
the transportation sector across he was
busy you know launching rockets but I'd
say you know building a SpaceX which is
amazing probably one of the most amazing
companies in in the country of the world
but he was busy doing that but we went
down and presented and he said
this I'm in I you know I I get the
vision I get the plan I want to be in so
then we had you know a lead investor and
we had our little VC's filling in the
the rest of the round and then once you
once you get funding the first time it
gets easier to get funding the second
time because if you meet your milestones
you have something to show and each time
you have something to show it
it D risks the investment so VCS are
more willing to put money in so we were
able to get sort of bigger money from
institution there from larger VC funds
with each subsequent round in fact yeah
yeah Ian right yeah right speed so I am
just wondering it you know outside of
the sector maybe in shipping or aviation
or trains you think there is potential
or sort of where the challenges is just
didn't even talk about those other
sectors and what ramifications this
might happen well so there are certain
things that probably it isn't
appropriate for I'd say you know the
last jet fuel I'm like really into jet
fuel so that would be I'm hoping the
very last of our hydrocarbon consumption
is going to be purely on jet fuel
because it's hard to do anything
electric with jets it's just there's
something special about that boats I'm
not so sure about they have a different
energy equation you know they're not
constrained by weight typically which is
great because cars are but of course
they're also not very efficient moving
through the water really now you can put
a lot of cargo on which makes the actual
energy content of the cargo that itself
quite low but I don't know if you could
really onboard enough battery energy you
know onto a freighter I've never done a
calculation it's knowable though you
could you know you could work it out it
and figure that out I think the big
sector is clearly long-haul trucking
needs to go away
because it should be on train it's so
much more efficient it's safer and
trains are super efficient and you know
all trains are electric even the diesel
the diesel trains or diesel electric
trains they actually have a diesel
generator that that generates
electricity to power the electric motors
that make the train go and there's
reasons for that dealing with torque and
it's the same reason why we can go super
quick is because you got to do this
giant master trying to accelerate you
can't clutch it because I miss you
clutch or just disintegrate on a train
so you have to have something that has
max torque at zero rpm like an electric
motor those things are easy to
decarbonize in the sense that if you in
Europe all the passenger rail is pretty
much a pure electric now so I mean
there's a path for that cars in trucks
you know or most of the equation so if
you if we solve that you know if we're
down at the other other things that's
great but all of it will you know it
will change and you know maybe the maybe
what you end up doing is you make jet
fuel and and a diesel fuel for the for
the big freighters you know in a
sustainable way you know you you
something that is consuming you knows
you biodiesel or something
the 7c here as you know exactly design
huge sevens here SUVs well they just did
the X is a giant seven seater SUV
no it's sevens yeah
no it's it's full-size that's crazy yes
giant giant I
I haven't actually driven one yet you
know I'm no longer with Tessa and I did
I couldn't make it to the event so but I
haven't driven one yet I want to see one
it's it's an awfully big car I'm
actually looking for a little bit
smaller I love my Model S it's just
awesome but I would like another one
that's a little smaller so from my
particular place in my life at this
moment I want something to worry about
you know 3-series BMW sighs so I'm
hoping that that's the next one that
they release yes what's your favorite
type of investment to make you're now on
the other side is an investor right so
we only invest in things we understand
and something that we would use
personally or at least could imagine
ourselves using so when somebody comes
and says I got this great new idea for a
video channel chat thing with social
media stuff not interested because we
don't do any of that like I would never
do that I have other things going out of
my life so we wouldn't invest in that
ideally it has if it's just the next
shiny object it's got to be really shiny
I guess most of the things that we've
invested we only made a few you know a
few investors were kind of new at this
but the things that we like our stuff
that has it's a cool technology that has
an implication sure so an example might
be we so we're investors in a company
that does very advanced kinds of lidar
because there's potentially a lot of
application for that both in
self-driving cars and other kinds of
mobility so you know that were that was
like right up our alley it was a
technical problem it was applying some
very difficult technology to a problem
to make something much cheaper and more
available that could have a societal
benefit so we kind of look for that we
don't always succeed but that's our goal
yeah
the the other side how do you weigh that
image value right there there's
obviously a value and being able to sell
this green and adjourn image of doing
something good how do you evaluate that
in terms of its ability to return profit
well it's a good question I mean you
know remember you know I'm not really a
VC I mean we just make these small
investments it has to be as I said you
know if we can envision a market for it
as something that we would want you know
it's sort of a narrow filter but I mean
that there are lots of things that we
can envision you know wanting there are
products that are very green but I can't
imagine why anyone would buy them
because they're not as good not nearly
as good as the existing unsustainable
non sustainable products so maybe
there'll be some green value to that I
mean people will disproportionately do
that or you know will pay a premium for
that or whatever but I don't believe
they'll do it for very long it's it's
got to be better and I think it's it's
not most things can be made better I
hope so I let me take a question from
from here there's one that I the first
one I about the energy density of
lithium ion batteries versus gasoline
and this is when it comes up a lot
gasoline is super energy dense right so
it's got I think maybe 40 kilowatt hours
per gallon energy and you know gallon of
gasoline it's not very big super energy
dense and the question is lithium-ion
batteries are nowhere near that so
they're never going to compete right
with with gasoline because gasoline is
so very energy dense but you're missing
the point
in that you don't actually care about
energy density what you care about is
mobility
so it isn't helmet is it what you really
want to ask is how much mobility do I
get from a gallon of gasoline however I
get it how much is that and it turns out
that gasoline although it's tremendously
energy dense it's super inefficient so
almost all of the energy
when you get into your car almost all of
the energy is wasted even in the most
efficient cars and you can test this so
when you go home
disconnect the cooling system from your
car just turn off that stuff and then
try to drive your car and see how long
it takes until your engine melts into a
puddle and it's only going to be a few
minutes because almost all of the energy
used in gasoline to power your car is
wasted as heat it's why you can turn the
heater on as you're going out of the
driveway and you have heat that heat
isn't manufactured just for you it's the
waste heat in fact if you stop getting
rid of all that waste heat the car melts
into a puddle because nearly almost none
of it is converted into forward motion
it's only like 20s are 17 18 percent is
converted into forward motion which if
you think about mobility and kilowatt of
energy it's just terrible electric
motors are nearly a hundred percent
efficient which is why when you think
about electric motor you don't think of
it with a radiator and pipes going
everywhere and ant you know in coolant
going through electric motors don't need
that because they're nearly a hundred
percent efficient I mean they generate
some heat but not very much and almost
all the energy that goes into an
electric motor is converted into
mechanical energy and what you really
want is how the thing that I want is
mechanical mobility how far does that
energy take you so a Tesla Model S has
the equivalent energy it's only got 85
kilowatt hours of battery pack that's
just a little over 2 gallons and yet it
has a 250 mile range so you know that's
all you know that if you had a car that
only had a 2 gallon tank
you wouldn't get 250 miles of range at
it because the the the gasoline is just
not very efficient if you think about
that it's an important point because
people think about air conditioning for
example and they talk about the
efficiencies of air conditioning these
are the you know electricity coming in
and what you really want to think about
is not that I mean that's a very good
measure but it's about generating cold
because what you actually want is cold
you don't want air conditioning
you don't want fans and blowers and
condensers what you really are your goal
is to get cold so if you had some device
that just produced cold but didn't
didn't have all that stuff that would be
a good thing but it might not know it
not measure up in the same way bit cold
is what you're after
mobility is what you're after it isn't
energy density of gasoline that has
nothing to do with what you want what
you want is mobility so that was one of
the questions from from the sheet here
yeah so we range anxiety you know oh my
gosh I'm gonna run out of energy and I
get stuck and it takes longer to refill
the car electric car we figured that
people and we did this by just asking
lots lots of people that we knew because
we couldn't afford any studies and I'm
always a little bit dubious of studies
when do you begin to feel nervous when
you're driving around and you're looking
for guests you know gas station and for
us everyone sit around 30 or 40 miles
when you have about 30 or 40 miles left
of range that's kind of when people
really begin to get nervous and need a
gas station so we figured that if we
made a car that had like a 50 mile range
like a leaf you would just be a wreck I
mean you know you you just always be you
know like freaking out so we picked a
number that was very very large because
we figured for 250 miles it would raise
the price but that would be okay because
we had to squash that particular fear
and people our customers have range
anxiety for a couple of days so once
they've driven it you know because every
morning you wake up you have that 250
mile range right so after people have
driven their cars for a few days they
realize wow I'm just doing everything I
normally do and I come back and I have
you know a hundred and eighty miles of
range left and then the next morning I
have 250 again all range anxiety goes
away and unless you're going on some
long trip which people almost never do
really they think about it they love the
imagery of it and when you ask them
about that you say what car do you take
because most cars are owned by
households
in California in America and households
have more than one car typically people
always have an answer they never just
say oh I just take whatever car I happen
to be driving
they say I always take the SUV because
we have lots of stuff I always take the
Prius because it gets good mileage I
always take they always take a
particular car so maybe it might be okay
if you take the other car for that one
long trip if you don't want to have and
this is before we had the superchargers
and then now people take the electric
cars on those long trips because the
superchargers aren't that bad but range
anxiety we think about 30 40 miles
people forget yes I haven't heard you
mention the economics of the
superchargers but my understanding is
the Tesla is giving people free charges
forever yeah that's so well I think
that's it yeah I mean remember Tesla
doesn't do any advertising and it
doesn't give any cars of discount and
doesn't you know do product placement so
if you think about the ad budget you can
choose to do that in a bunch of
different ways and if putting super
charges around is a great advertisement
I think it's a great plan I love that
idea when they came out I thought that
was it was clever and the thing is that
most people don't really use them
because most people don't drive to LA
and by the way we always were asked this
question about what if you want to drive
to LA if you're in San Francisco we were
asked that question I don't know four or
five hundred times probably raising
money and stuff or just customers what
if I want to drive to LA if you're in LA
we never heard that question they always
say what if you want to drive to Vegas
and we heard that hundreds of times what
if you want to go to Vegas so I want you
to just think about that in terms of the
sort of cultural aspects of Southern
California and Northern California it's
got to be a PhD service in there I'm
just sure it was a hundred percent we
never ever I mean it was it was it
became kind of a joke because every time
we go it was the same question
you see oh this one questions is do you
think that shouldn't you let you know is
it easier is it is easier for a start-up
to do a green product or should you just
let large companies just change their
ways and do a green products at less
there's tons of pressure they will never
change because they're super good at
what they do and you know big companies
need to get kicked to to make it change
Volkswagen I think is going to make a
change with that too in the near future
which i think is pretty good anything
else here oh there was a question about
the t zero somebody knows deep dark
Tesla you know history the T zero we
didn't make it says you know when you
built the teaser we didn't build the T
zero the T zero was a a car that was
built by AC propulsion it was a sort of
hobbyist is this AC propulsion had the
most advanced electric drivetrains at
the time and we did a lot of research
remember we studied how are we gonna you
know we're a bunch of software people
and hardware people how are we gonna
make electric cars you study everything
and you look for everyone that's doing
anything interesting AC propulsion had
the best stuff and they had a car that
they had made I called the T zero it was
made of fiberglass and piping and you
know as a sort of a kid car that they
hope to eventually get into real
production which you know would never
happen it would never pass crash but we
borrowed that on numerous occasions and
actually we paid to have lithium-ion
batteries we had an early designer we
paid to have them put in lithium-ion
batteries and to see if it would really
do what we thought it would do as part
of our validation of the technology and
then we borrowed it for fund raising and
they were quite gracious to let us
borrow it
from time to time so that's what the T
zero comes from
and let's see oh that's too complicated
yeah much else here less entrepreneurial
ecosystems Oh what lies ahead for the
electric car industry there is a slow
Moore's law the batteries get better
every year the big thing is cheapness
the cheaper the batteries get the more
applicable they become if batteries were
half the price they are now two-thirds
of the cars outside would be electric I
think because they're really fun to
drive they're way more fun than a
gasoline-powered car my son just turned
16 he got his driver's license you know
two weeks ago and along the way is he
drive the test he's like dad you know
this this is really fun to drive this is
better and I was like yeah you know
that's it's true it really is it's a
better it is better so but the issue is
the cost of batteries and the density it
may be that the only way that you can
get the price down is to increase the
energy density that that may be the case
it probably is but even if the energy
density didn't get better which I think
it is but even if it hits if that
stopped as long as the price curve
continued to come down that would be
okay because we can make compelling cars
with the existing energy density it's
just they have you have to have a lot of
batteries having higher energy density I
think it's probably gonna be the way to
make them cheaper but that's the the
single biggest thing and I believe there
will be a tipping point where you know
electric cars remain somewhat exotic
they you know are a little bit pricey
they're somewhat exotic that continue
along and then there's going to be this
moment where suddenly the price barrier
is hit just right and then everybody
just goes oh well I'll just buy one of
those I think it'll be big because the
other thing is that you don't have to
stop at gas stations so the flipside of
range anxiety is that you never need to
stop at gas stations which I've driven
50,000 miles on my Model S and if I just
work that out compared to my Audi a4
that I had before that's about 11 hours
standing assuming it takes five minutes
per refueling at a gas station that's
about 11 hours of time that I've saved
over the last two years and you know I
don't miss that at all I never think oh
I should just go to the gas station
stand there I mean it's it just never
occurs to me because I never have to
stop going like I'm never racing to a
class or a meeting and go oh shoot I've
got to get gas that never happens to me
because in the morning I have a full
tank and it takes two seconds to plug it
in yeah when break into the totally new
industry like that at what point you
feel like you've acquired enough
knowledge by like you know renting books
from the library and search on the
internet by yourself and figuring out
what if what it takes to build a car and
think that if you feel comfortable going
out and talking to someone and not feel
like you're you know totally out of your
element they're just good you know you
take it seriously oh I don't know if we
were ever taken seriously but it's you
know somewhere along the line you know
it just kind of happens somebody had
asked about Lotus how we got a deal with
Lotus and what you know chosen so that's
an example of being taken seriously so
to get that deal with Lotus Martin and I
went to the LA Auto Show and we had
heard this is before we had funding you
know so when we were working on the
business plan the LA Auto Show is
January or February
December or something and we went down
there and we knew that Lotus was going
to show there and we heard that there
might be people from Lotus that weren't
just sales people there so you go to the
LA Auto Show and they have you know the
cars and there's the salespeople out in
front that talk about the car and we
said no no we need to talk to some of
those other people in the back and we
just wouldn't leave the booth we spent
about 45 minutes harassing the the poor
people in the front until finally they
led us through the little you know roped
off thing into the backroom where at the
back of their booth where there were
guys from Lotus Engineering that did
contract manufacturing you know and and
then we just did it hardcore press I
said well if you're you know we come to
Hefele which is where they're based in
England you know this is you know we
continue this conversation Hethel
and that was clearly a filter for them
because if we were just to nutcases
which they run into
of nutcases not only was electric car
but just regular ones they're not going
to fly to England so he said great and
so you know a couple of weeks later you
know we flew to England much to their
surprise and worked with him there and
ultimately we got a letter of a letter
of intent that basically said if you
guys are not in you know totally insane
and if you actually have money we might
write a contra who might sign a contract
with you and that we used that to be
funding that was that was enough
let me included the letter in our
funding our due diligence package and
stuff so that was beginning to be
credible in a sense so we started on
July 1st of 2003 and the letter intent
was before we went to raise money so
nine months probably eight months yeah
it was you know we spent a lot of time
trying to figure out if we could even do
it and it was not obvious
no because we were considered so
marginal and pathetic and yet another
one of these electric things that was
never going to happen that we never felt
that way the car companies just didn't
consider us to be car company car
company and the gas companies couldn't
possibly perceive any threat so I think
eventually they will but at the moment
they don't and you can see this class
and smart people in here thinking about
this what would be a dream of what
somebody in this roadway dream about
taking on that would be oh there's lots
filled with these terrible problems one
thing is if you can fix energy I mean is
solar is getting really good and we need
we need big scale energy storage because
if we actually had cheap big scale
energy storage solar power for most of
the country would be the cheapest
possible energy we could have I like
efficiency are like you know LED lights
and everything else I've done all of
that but ultimately we just want more
power we want to have a lot more energy
because energy makes all the problems
easier to solve we you know are
obviously in a terrible drought here if
we had tons of energy we could just use
we know how to make you know fresh water
from salt water it's just super energy
expensive so making that more efficient
that's great but maybe just making tons
of energy would be a good plan too it's
you know kind of a brute force thing but
it just makes every everything easy the
only way to recycle some of the little
things that are in your cell phone and
stuff that I know of is to essentially
vaporize it and then have it condense
out very energy intensive did you get
100% back so you know it if you have
energy these lots of problems suddenly
become solvable so I think energy would
be great
farming is a big thing we got to fix
that well just just you know sort of
energy farming water transportation you
know the you know biodiversity you got
to go to help there so anything along
those lines be good Oh big space solar
space satellites yeah I I've always
wondered about that yeah it's just that
beaming thing down I mean like I'm not
sure I really wanted to live underneath
that microwave antenna but maybe it
would work I don't know it seems
expensive it's got it you know we want
to have lots of energy so but maybe
that's the way to do it
any questions thank you so much for
coming
you